un quoi qu'il en coûte électorale voilà
comment l'opposition définit le
comportement d' emmanuel macron depuis
début septembre les remontrances se font
de plus en plus mis qu emmanuel macron
fait campagne avec le chéquier de la
france le quoi qu'il en coûte est
terminée pour les français mais il ne
fait que commencer pour la campagne des
manuels macron en quinze jours entre 5
et 7 milliards d'euros ont été dépensés
juin 2020 en pleine crise du coc vide je
déposé une proposition de loi pour
attribuer un deuxième chèque énergie aux
ménages les plus précaires rejeté par
arm ce mois ci le gouvernement augmente
le montant du chèque énergie six mois
avant l'élection
coïncidence je ne pense pas valérie
pécresse va même plus loin et accusent
le chef de l'état je cite de cramer la
caisse il est vrai que si le président
n'est officiellement pas encore candidat
cette fin de mandat riche de promesses
ressemble de plus en plus à une campagne
en vue de 2022 ce qui se traduit à
travers ses différentes sorties à chaque
visite ça dépend sortons un calcul 1
milliard 500 millions d'euros promis à
marseille un déplacement de trois jours
des rencontres et des annonces pour la
ville de coeur du président pour les
transports la sécurité la culture et la
rénovation des écoles 500 millions
promis via le beauvau de la sécurité la
semaine dernière 600 millions versées en
chaque énergie 2 milliards consacrés à
la rénovation énergétique
un plan de 300 millions d'euros pour les
travailleurs indépendants 40 millions
d'euros pour le versement d'une prime et
la revalorisation des salaires des
sages-femmes 600 millions d'euros dédiés
en assurance récolte pour les
agriculteurs ou encore une enveloppe de
400 millions d'euros pour le
développement des transports en commun
des collectivités de province même
demandé pardon à un coût la preuve en
est avec les harkis à qui le chef de
l'état a promis une loi de
reconnaissance mais surtout de futurs
réparation sonnantes et trébuchantes
le souvenir des harkis
l'honneur des harkis doit être gravé
dans la mémoire nationale
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement portera
avant la fin de l'année un projet
visant à inscrire dans le marbre de nos
lois la reconnaissance et la réparation
à l'égard des harkis
je m'y engage
une réparation pour l'heure impossible à
chiffrer mais qui s'inscrit dans cette
politique de cadeaux à tout va or cette
dernière si on fait le total c'est
environ 6 milliards d'euros promis par
emmanuel macron alors avec quel argent
elle est la question le fameux argent
magique dont le chef de l'état contesté
l'existence semble couler à flots pour
bon nombre d'économistes qui
s'inquiètent pour le taux d'endettement
du pays
bordeaux le maire qui annonçait fin août
la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte doit en
faire des cauchemars le ministre de
l'économie elle présentera à cette
semaine un budget avec déjà quasiment 5%
de déficit au grand dam de la cour des
comptes qui a tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
selon elle les dépenses courantes en
matière d'éducation de sécurité de
justice ou de santé ont déjà écouté 14
milliards d'euros à l'hexagone en 2020
on arrive à des niveaux d'endettement
assez élevé à un moment il faudra
stabiliser la dette si on engage des
dépenses récurrentes il faut prévoir des
recettes pérennes en face ne pas le
faire serait assez démagogique un
qualificatif dont le chef de l'état ne
semble avoir cure en ces temps de pré
campagne reste à savoir si toutes ces
promesses seront réalisés surtout
réalisable car comme le soulignait en
son temps jacques chirac les promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui les reçoivent